it turns out the areas of these two
shapes are
the same or they can at least be worked
out in the same way
and the reason why is because you build
them the same way
right rhombuses are a special kind of
kite if you want to think about it like
that
so what we've got here what we'll need
is rather than like length
and breadth and all that kind of thing
is what you need to draw is the
diagonals
of your kite okay so connect up the
opposite points
and let's get our diagonals in
now if you have drawn your kite
accurately
and you've got two pairs of sides that
are actually equal to each other
then when you draw the diagonals you
ought to notice something a bit unusual
right that the diagonals they meet in a
particular way and if you can look
over at your neighbors whose kite
hopefully looks a bit different
your diagonals they're diagonals should
do the same thing even though your kites
are different
you can even see it on mine roughly what
is it about these diagonals how do they
meet how do they intersect
okay so you've got diagonals here of a
kind and thank you very much andrew
and here they are at right because
they're perpendicular
okay and here's the thing though you
can't just kind of say oh
they look kind of perpendicular right
things often
look like something but it's not enough
to just say well
that's close enough right we're
mathematicians we can prove
that it's perpendicular no matter what
client you draw
we can do it and in fact the whole point
is that all different kinds it'll work
okay so here's now my question
i have a question mark here i'm trying
to work out what is that
angle can i prove that it's equal to
what i think
what we think it is equal to okay how
are you going to go about doing it
all right so you got your diagram there
um we're going to put some labels on
this okay
so firstly have a look at this with me
see how these two
sides are equal to each other yes
so i'm going to label them as such so
that equal
to this can you see it is that
reasonably clear
yeah okay and then you've got these two
equal right so i'll mark
them as such as well
okay so what kinds of things do you
notice well
have a look at this top triangle right
and the one that is opposite underneath
okay
can you see that those triangles the top
one and the bottom one
they have so many things in common right
how many things can you see
jake um they have the
two sides that are the same and they
yeah sure um both
of them sorry yeah good and then they
share the same face
right very good okay i'm gonna stop i'm
just gonna draw it okay
uh very good that's exactly right so
you've got two pairs of equal sides one
two
one two and then you've got this one in
the middle it's the same side so we call
it a common sign
right so therefore these two triangles
the top triangle
and the bottom triangle likely to have
this um on the side of your diagram
there
now we have a special word for when
shapes are
not just a little bit alike but exactly
alike it starts with a c does anyone
know
congruent very good so we've got two
congruent triangles it means in every
single way
all the angles all the sides everything
the triangles are the same
okay they match up if i were to flip
them around they'd sit exactly
on top of each other i know we're upside
down but they're still the same
dimensions same size all that kind of
thing
so if they're congruent we can say some
things about the angles for instance
and take this one off now so see how
you've got this angle and this angle
right see how they match
they're the same angle just upside down
from each other
right so i can say they're equal to each
other is that right
so for example i can put alpha and alpha
there i can say they're equal is that
all right you content with that
they're both the same perfect all right
the next thing i want you to notice is
hold on a second look at this left hand
triangle right we talked about top
bottom before
but now i have a look at this left hand
triangle i'll outline it for you
this one here what kind of
triangle is this red triangle
it's isosceles right good so it's got
these two equal angles when you've got
an isosceles triangle
what can you say about it
i've got two equal sides that's what i
knew already which means i've also got
two equal angles which ones
these yeah these top and bottom ones
right so i can say they're equal as well
right so let's give another name to
these ones let's call this one
beta and this one's beta
is that okay yeah so far so good all
right now have a look at this red
triangle now
i now know what the angles
all in this triangle are or equal to
right
this red triangle if i draw it like this
off on the side
okay you've got beta here b to here
what's this angle equal to
i've got two of these right
except for the fact that it's alpha but
yes that's exactly right
you are so close okay there you go two
alpha
okay you can do it on the side so now we
can work out what this thing is equal to
right all of the angles in a triangle
two alpha plus beta plus beta right
what do all the angles in a triangle add
up to 180 100 degrees very good
right that's the angle sum of a triangle
so now help me out here we can make this
a little bit simpler a little bit
right i've got two alpha and i've got
two beta
and then i've got 180 degrees over here
yep
so i can divide everything
through in this line by what's the
common factor
what do all of these numbers have in
common
i can take out a factor of two can't i
all these numbers are even
right so i'm going to divide this by two
this by two and this by two see that do
the same thing to everything
okay see what's going
okay so you can see it these two's going
to cancel you just get alpha
these twos are going to cancel you'll
just get beta and then you do 180
degrees divided by 2
which is 90 degrees all right now why is
this significant
and why does this get us to what we're
after right
come back to your original kite right
and i hope you've got your kite there
might look a little bit different right
see how alpha and beta are here in this
triangle
right well i'm going to do that whole
angle something all over again right
alpha plus beta they must be they're 90
right so i've got one last angle
and it has to be 90 degrees in order to
get the 180 that a total triangle has to
be
okay so now i'm not just guessing and
i'm just saying ah it kind of looks like
it
i've proven it the logic holds no matter
what kite you present to me
all 30 kites that are in the room
they're all going to have the same
properties even if they look different
does that make sense okay
so what was the whole point of that the
whole point of that is now we can get an
area out of this
right i need one more color
we put di diagrams on here okay so
let's call this up and down one we'll
call it
x so all the way up and down
is x okay and all the way across we'll
call that y
so what's the area of this thing now
remember you've got a right angle in
here don't you
yeah you got a right angle in there so
how can we take advantage of that
yes good so you're 90k which means you
have 90 there as well so in fact all of
those
they'll all be 90. here's the way i'll
help you out right
let's just look at let's come back to
this top triangle right
because once you say something about the
top triangle you can say about the
bottom one okay
what's the area what's the area of that
top triangle
we already know how to do triangle areas
right what's the it's half base height
right half
times what's the base of that top
triangle
it's it's y
half base what's the height hold on be
careful here
yeah all the way from here to here is x
right but we just went to the point of
saying the top and the bottom triangle
are the same
so this should be the same as this so
that should just be half
right half x okay
right so let's put this all together
yeah i'll say it again
so i'm doing half base height yeah
half the base is y there he is
and the height is this bit here look at
the top triangle okay
if this all the way is x then this is
halfway
therefore half x is that okay all right
i'm so close we're so close half times a
half
half of a half is a quarter
okay and then rather than just writing
all these multiplication signs i'll just
say
x y okay so that's the area of the top
triangle
if the top triangle is congruent to the
bottom triangle
what's the area of the bottom triangle
they're exactly the same in everywhere
right it should be the same
right so this should be um the area of
the bottom triangle as well
yes so therefore the area of the kite
the total area it's this
and then this again because i've got two
of them two of those triangles right
we halved half there and we got a
quarter
well now we want to put one back right
so two of those will just be half
there's your area formula right there
okay now the cool thing about this and
the reason why i had all my extra sides
before
right is that a kite and a rhombus are
really the same
kind of shape it's just that the rhombus
has
more equal sides right so you have this
guy over here
and then you've got this guy over here
so therefore not only is the area of a
kite half x y
half times the diagonals right but the
area of
a rhombus is also the same so long as
you have its diagonals
you have its area similar kinds of
shapes
same formula for working out how much
space it takes up
yep
these two angles why are they equal
because you've got the top triangle
and the bottom triangle everything about
them is equal
that's what we mean by congruent so if
everything about them is equal then
the angle is rooted
all right you did a really good job to
follow along with that
here it is i promise this is the last
[ __ ] on any of these